hey how you doing hey how you do it
hey how you doing I'm good
you're new here right yes I work the
night shift my name is Park well it's
very nice meeting you Bart what it's
nice to meet you
sorry I have to practice what to say hey
how you doing
I watch people and I imitate if you
watch people well
I study them yeah well I guess you have
a lot of people to watch at the hotel
yes me too
[Music]
we have a dead woman here and I think
Bart knows something about we found your
fingerprints all over the room
this is a fragile boy and you need to
understand that look I know you got
issues but you're hiding something
that's what I really believe barn I
drove home I mean I watch I watched TV
a very smart guy and yet what you're
saying to me doesn't make sense you know
you can tell me anything honey
[Music]
he has kind of an odd way about it but
you know that doesn't mean he did
anything does it oh god oh god oh god
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
Bart what did you do what did you do
what did you do part what did you do
[Music]
you
you